Bangladesh es el único país islámico presidido
por una mujer; Sheikh Hasina ¡Y no se trata
de un ejemplo insustancial! Hablamos del 3º
país más grande del mundo musulmán, con
más 170 millones de habitantes.
Sin embargo, este país ha dado a gente mucho
más famosa que su presidenta. Efectivamente,
hablamos de Muhammad Yunus, premio Nobel de
la Paz y conocido mundialmente por el banquero
que inventó los microcréditos. Esto es sorprendente
si tenemos en cuenta que su país es una de
las sociedades menos bancarizadas del mundo.
Sólo 1 de cada 3 Bangladeshies tiene cuenta
en el banco.
Tal cual como lo oís. Da igual que Bangladesh
es una de las economías que más rápido
ha crecido en los últimos años. Da igual
que sean el segundo fabricante de ropa del
mundo, sólo por detrás de China. Da igual
que cada vez haya menos pobres. La mayoría
de los ciudadanos de Bangladesh todavía guardan
su dinero en un calcetín.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué? ¿Qué pasa
en Bangladesh para que desconfíen de los
bancos? La respuesta está en la religión.
Según el Islam, prestar dinero con intereses
es pecado. Y el 90% de los Bangladeshíes
son musulmanes.
¡Pero esperad un momento por las cosas han
cambiado! Desde hace años, los países musulmanes
han inventado un sistema que permite cumplir
con los preceptos del Islam y, a la vez, ahorrar
dinero y pedir prestamos ¡Exacto! Hablamos
de la banca islámica. Un fenómeno cada vez
más importante en Bangladesh.
Sin embargo, para el gobierno de Sheikh Hasina,
esto no son buenas noticias, precisamente.
“Banco Islami: los banqueros más vigilados
de Bangladesh”
Con este panorama la pregunta es ¿Por qué
el Gobierno de Bangladesh desconfía de la
banca islámica? Y lo que es más importante
¿Qué papel puede desempeñar lo que está
pasando con la banca islámica en el futuro
de Bangladesh? Hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas. Pero antes… vamos a responder
a otra pregunta aún más urgente…
¿QUÉ ES LA BANCA ISLÁMICA?
Imaginad que metemos 1000 dólares en una
cuenta de ahorro. Un banco occidental nos
ofrece una rentabilidad del 3%, por ejemplo.
Seguramente muchos os habréis preguntado
alguna vez ¿Cómo es posible que el banco
pueda darnos dinero guardarlo? ¿Dónde está
su beneficio? Pues bien, lo cierto es que
esos 1000 dólares que hemos ingresado no
se quedan en la caja fuerte del banco sino
que se utilizan para prestárselo a otros
individuos o empresas. Esos préstamos se
ofrecen con un tipo de interés con lo que
el banco gana dinero y a nosotros nos da una
parte de esos beneficios.
Este es el esquema básico de nuestro sistema
bancario. Por supuesto que hay muchos mecanismos
para evitar riesgos. Por ejemplo, dependiendo
del país en el que estemos, los bancos tendrían
que guardar un porcentaje de esos 1000 dólares
y no podían prestarlo. A ese porcentaje se
le llama “coeficiente de caja”.
Pues bien, según la sharía, este sistema
está pervertido porque prestar con un tipo
de interés es pecado de usura. Por supuesto
que tu puedes guardar el dinero de tus clientes.
Pero no puedes prestárselo a nadie, y mucho
menos con un tipo de interés. En jerga económica,
esto significa que es la sharía exige un
sistema con coeficiente de caja del 100%.
Pues bien, este es el funcionamiento de la
banca islámica.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo ganan dinero estos
bancos? Pues, principalmente, de dos maneras:
por un lado, cobrando comisiones por guardar
el dinero. Es más, a diferencia de los bancos
occidentales, que nos dan un interés por
guardar nuestro dinero, los bancos islámicos
solo pueden hacer algún regalo simbólico
a sus clientes, lo que se conoce con el nombre
de HIBAB.
Otro negocio que sí pueden hacer los bancos
islámicos es el cobro de plusvalías. Por
ejemplo, imaginad que compramos una casa con
un banco islámico. En este caso, es la entidad
quien compra la casa por nosotros y nos la
revende a un precio más alto, la llamada
MUSHARAKA, que podemos devolver en cómodos
plazos. Si, por lo que sea, no podemos terminar
de pagar la vivienda, el banco la volvería
a poner a la venta y, si sacara algún beneficio,
nosotros nos llevaríamos la mitad.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
todo! El Corán también prohíbe a los bancos
islámicos invertir en lo que consideran “actividades
impuras” como, por ejemplo, el tabaco, la
producción de armas o la pornografía. Es
más existe toda una guía de empresas donde
está permitido invertir, el llamado DOW JONES
ISLAMIC MARKETS, con más de 1400 valores.
Como os podéis imaginar, este tipo de bancos
están arrasando en casi todo el mundo musulmán.
Pero en Bangladesh es una auténtica locura.
La banca islámica está creciendo rápidamente
en Bangladesh con un una cuota de mercado
de casi el 20%
Hoy ya hay 8 bancos de este tipo en Bangladesh.
Incluso algunos bancos como CITIBANK están
empezando a ofrecer servicios de banca islámica
a los clientes que lo solicitan.
En un país donde los sobornos están presentes
en múltiples aspectos de la vida cotidiana,
la banca islámica se ha ganado una reputación
de transparencia y buena praxis. Si por un
aspecto se caracterizaba hasta ahora el Islami
Bank de Bangladesh era por permanecer ajeno
al Gobierno. De esta forma, digamos que si
querías conseguir un crédito necesitabas
garantizar cierta solvencia, mientras que
en la banca tradicional nada era más efectivo
que tener un padrino en la administración
o dar la propina o soborno adecuado a la persona
adecuada.
¡Pero esperad un momento! ¡Porque las cosas
no pintan también para la banca islámica
como parece!
BANCO BUENO, BANCO MALO
La banca islámica llegó en 1983 a Bangladesh
de la mano de fondos saudíes y kuwaitíes
que crearon el Islami Bank. Tuvo un papel
vital con su financiación para convertir
a un país que era principalmente agrícola
en una de las principales fábricas de ropa
del mundo. De hecho hoy día el sector textil
supone un 80% de las exportaciones de Bangladesh
y el Islami Bank es el principal banco del
país desde hace años.
Sin embargo, el crecimiento de la banca islámica
en el país está ahora en cuestión.
El Banco central de Bangladesh no dará nuevas
licencias para bancos islámicos
Incluso esos bancos occidentales que quieren
dar servicios de banca islámica tienen que
esperar. El Banco central de Bangladesh ha
decidido no dar más licencias con el pretexto
de que se necesita una mayor regulación en
la materia.
Mientras tanto, el Gobierno de Sheikh Hasina
ha mandado a inspectores a las oficinas del
Islami Bank y está registrando todos sus
movimientos.
El Gobierno de Bangladesh inicia un golpe
al banco más grande del país.
Los miembros de la Junta directiva reciben
una visita de la inteligencia militar.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué problema tiene el
gobierno de Bangladesh con la banca islámica?
Pues… como os podéis imaginar, la respuesta
oficial del gobierno de Bangladesh es la lucha
contra el terrorismo. Como explicábamos en
este otro vídeo, el integrismo islámico
es cada vez más problemático en este país.
Y no son pocos quienes sospechan que alguno
de estos bancos podría estar financiando
a grupos terroristas.
Sin embargo… hay muchas razones que nos
llevan a pensar que, en el fondo, se trata
de una lucha de poder.
Si algo le gusta a Sheikh Hasina es tener
las cosas bajo control. Y que el principal
banco del país, con todo su poder económico,
tenga mayores simpatías por las propuestas
del principal partido de la oposición, ese
que engloba a los integrantes del partido
islámico, no es algo que Hasina esté dispuesta
a tolerar.
Por eso, cuando este mes de enero, Hasina
intervino el Islami Bank, terminó cambiando
a su directiva y colocó a personas más afines.
Desde entonces, los préstamos se ha ndisparado
y, según el propio Banco central de Bangladesh,
sin atender a los criterios de riesgo adecuados.
Mientras tanto, los fondos inversores de Arabia
Saudí y Kuwait que crearon el banco hace
35 años han tomado nota y han reducido su
participación. No creen que su dinero esté
ahora seguro.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta no es
la primera vez que Sheikh Hasina intenta controlar
al poder financiero en su país! ¿Os acordáis
de Mohammad Yunus? Pues… también está
en el punto de mira de Hasina.
En el año 2006, tras varios atentados islamistas,
el ejército dio un golpe de estado y formó
un gobierno tecnócrata. Por aquel entonces
sonó con mucha fuerza el nombre de Yunus
como opción para presidir el país. Finalmente
la opción Yunus no se concretó, pero Hasina
aprendió la lección: cuidado con los banqueros.
A veces les da por meterse en política.
Por eso, lo primero que hizo Hasina al tomar
el gobierno, 2 años más tarde, fue encargarse
de Yunus. Para empezar, le destituyó de su
cargo en el banco Grameen, el banco que el
propio Yunus había fundado. Por supuesto
que muchas de las acusaciones que lanzó contra
este banquero eran ciertas. De hecho, Yunus
tampoco es una mosquita muerta. Pero de eso
hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Lo cierto es que, si destituirle de su cargo
no era suficiente, Hasina emprendió una campaña
para desprestigiarle.
Hasina asegura que el premio Nobel Yunus consiguió
que Hillary Clinton detenga los fondos del
Banco Mundial para el puente de Padma
En otras palabras, que Sheikh Hasina sabe
cómo derrotar a sus enemigos políticos.
Primero era Yunus, ahora es la banca islámica.
Así que la pregunta es ¿De verdad hay una
conexión entre la banca islámica y el terrorismo?
¿O es una excusa del Gobierno de Bangladesh
para poder tener las finanzas bajo control?
¿Debería Bangladesh permitir que la banca
islámica siga desarrollando su actividad
con total normalidad? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis saber más sobre
esta parte del mundo, en este otro vídeo
os hablamos del conflicto en el Himalaya entre
China y la India. Haced click aquí para verlo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.